[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
we'll talk to John worthheim
he is a 60 Minutes correspondent
did a story on Sports washing he went to
Saudi Arabia sat down with the
minister of sports over there kind of
figuring out what is the uh bigger
picture what other sports would they
like to invest in and John joins us now
John thanks for joining us what concerns
you or should concern you or us about
the so-called partnership that the Saudi
Investment fund has with the PGA Tour
moving forward well the the micro as
we're seeing just how rough this all is
and how hastily this came together and
how many steps still need to be
completed how much you know it still has
to pass Regulators a lot of details even
this five six page framework that we saw
still sort of leaves more questions
unanswered than answered and I think the
bigger picture is just what is our
comfort level with this investment fund
and this kind of money coming into
sports some some of this is the you know
the morals that Jay Monahan among others
have alluded to but also some of this is
just what does it do to sports when one
of the players has a completely
different set of Economics than
everybody else well you've talked about
this that your return on investment most
people get into sports by a team and
there's a return on investment the
Saudis aren't concerned about that
well I they want to return on investment
it's just a much different uh much
different account you know Dan Snyder or
whatever uh you know Josh Harris buys a
team from Dan Snyder and he's oh here
are broadcast contracts and here are the
sweeps and here's some real estate play
I can make this is a completely
different set of math with the Saudis
this is about rebranding a country and
there's this Vision 2030 plan with the
sort of national plan to completely
transform the country and sports figures
very prominently
um that's a lot different of a balance
sheet than are we selling enough Suites
and are we going to get our media rights
renewed but are they really trying to
change are they are they trying to give
the appearance that they're trying to
change
that's that's a great question and when
I went to Saudi Arabia I mean to their
credit I
sat down across from the sports Minister
and they made him available and on the
one hand they were saying you know
we don't even we don't even think Sports
watching is a thing look we're lucky
enough to have a lot of money and we're
going to invest in sports it's a great
way to motivate the kids we have a young
population we'll put down your your
phone and your chalupa and start running
laps and it's a great way to and then on
the other hand they said look at all
these cranes we're really trying to
update our economy we're trying to
diversify look at all this growth and
development and tourism so on the one
hand this sort of you know it's not
about throwing money around it's not
about laundering a reputation it's just
about helping the kids and then they
would pivot and say sports is one of the
pillars of this National transformation
how nervous were you
this Jamal khashoggi you know this this
murder dismemberment five years later is
still the first thing that people cling
onto when everyone's trying to build a
sports watch in case this is the first
thing that they have to answer for and I
think that um you know it's it's crass
and vulgar to think of it in these terms
but this was a horrible mistake that
probably cost them a trillion dollars I
mean this is the very the very first
thing when Sports watching comes up is
the dismemberment of a journalist and so
uh I I think they know that they have a
lot to answer for and this is uh you
know they've there's a set of talking
points and they still deny the content
of the CIA report that uh that this went
all the way up to NBA to the Mohamed
on Modern Crown Prince and that he
had either ordered it or okayed it they
still take issue with that but I think
they know that um this is something
that's sort of this murder I think has
accelerated all of this investment in
sports watching because they've really
had to double down on saying to the rest
of the world hey wait we're just like
you we love Bruno Mars and we love uh
you know the NBA Golf and soccer as well
uh what else is will the Saudis Buy
NFL NBA baseball are they interested in
that
absolutely I mean part of it is just we
all love sports these franchises don't
go down in value it's a great way to
build Bridges and tear down walls I mean
I also did just practically these teams
get bought by individuals and when it's
you know when it's March shot and you
know Red McCombs on the local car deal
we're not in that era anymore I mean
these are you know these are four five
six billion dollar properties they're
not a lot of individuals
that have that spare change lying around
I mean I just think as franchise values
go up
um it stands to reason that we're gonna
have to go outside the U.S to find these
these billionaires but um you know these
investment funds we saw this week that
you know tedley owns this in a
Washington it's not Saudi it's Qatari
but they're taking a minority stake and
you know the Wizards and the mystics and
the capitals we're seeing in you know
inevitably now there was an announcement
a few days ago that that Saudi is
looking into partnering with tennis I
mean I think this beach had this sort of
normalization with the PGA I think is
going to lead to a much bigger Saudi
presence in sports you know I mean I
think we got to spend 30 seconds I don't
maybe it's not a bad thing maybe this
really is a way to break down boundaries
um you know the the athletes love it
values you know money is getting look at
the PGA Tour I mean money is being
inserted into the ecosystem I mean
I think we're all rightfully cynical but
I also think that we they're out we
ought to reserve like a little column
for hey maybe this isn't a bad thing
yeah I know we can be hypocritical in a
variety of fronts here uh we're talking
to John worthheim the uh uh 60 Minutes
correspondent I'm also wondering about
this that you had this back and forth
with uh this Saudi uh I I don't know
what his official title is the Minister
of sports where you were talking about
um you know the beheadings that they had
like 80 people who were beheaded if
that's the number and then he brought up
well you had this mass shooting in Texas
and then you said yeah but that wasn't
government ordered there and I thought
it was an interesting exchange between
you two what what was the room like when
that exchange happened John
yeah um there were some tense moments
there I mean I think the The Playbook
and we saw this right I mean I sort of
got a little preview some sometimes you
uh you go back you you do your research
and you sort of anticipate what
responses are and in this case I think
the golfers gave me a lot of uh a lot of
sense of what to anticipate because
everyone's got the same talking points
which is no one is perfect we all wish
we lived in a peaceful world you know
wake me up tea without the first you
know if you if you live in a perfect
country raise your hand
um I would say there ought to be some
some basic standards and yeah I mean
mass shootings are terrible we wish we
didn't have them but I I would submit
there's a difference between that and
especially when I mean the other part of
that is especially when a the state
actor is the one making the investment
and B when this is part of a strategy
um you know people have also I don't
understand you have an iPhone or how
come we don't care that the Saudi has a
big take in Facebook and so many
American companies they they haven't
invested in Facebook as a strategy for
rebranding the country and I think
that's the distinction I would make one
of the first stories you did I think for
60 minutes was profiling show
what you knew then or found out then and
where he is now
uh I think we're trying to understand
what what motivates him and and you know
the surroundings that he's in and free
agency and does he want to be in New
York you know he's on the periphery of
La by being in Anaheim
did you like glean anything from him of
his personality and and and what makes
him comfortable
he has a really weird mix that would be
weird I mean it was really sort of
fascinating mix of
Supreme confidence right I mean he
wasn't going to let some agent he wasn't
going to let some manager I mean he
wanted to play both ways and he was
absolutely firm that he could do it and
he would do it I mean it was a deal
breaker and at the same time there was
such a humility he had no interest and
you know I people say well you know he's
only going to end up on one of three
markets because you have a star like
that and all the money he could make and
I had people close to him saying they
don't understand him he loves baseball
he loves his family he's a simple guy he
doesn't want the publicity he's not
interested in going to the the hottest
club in South Beach or living in lower
Manhattan and I think in a weird way it
was appropriate I mean he went to a West
Coast you know obviously it's closer to
home marginally so
um
it's all about the baseball and it
sounds like such a cliche but you know
you'd ask him what do you do for fun and
he would have a hard time remembering
because his favorite place to eat in
Sapporo but then you'd mentioned Clayton
Kershaw and his eyes would light up um
he was a fascinating guy but but I think
again it's sort of our theme for the
conversation he has a different set of
motivations than what we are used to
this is not about doing production deals
on a podcast and maxing out his
endorsement portfolio
um different economics I wonder if that
bodes well for the Angels
because they let him pitch and hit and
there's there's a comfort level there
and it feels like he gets into a routine
he's simple he likes the routine he
likes the people he likes the
environment it's a hundred percent and I
think that uh you know if somebody's
Whispering his ear hey come to this the
snazzy big big I can get you a meeting
with so and so and you'll sit courtside
at Knicks games I think he loves that
he's not even the biggest team in the
market he's in and he's in Orange County
I mean he I mean even now that story I
think was 2017 I mean how many long
sit-down interviews have you seen
um he keeps himself he goes to the
ballpark he loves baseball they're not
hassling him about it you know pitch
counts and we we want to cut down on
your starts
you wish the team were winning more
games I think baseball wishes a team
were more relevant I think it's kind of
a perfect situation for him what's your
next Sports Story coming up
oh man
um for for 60. I'm heading to Wimbledon
I had to Wimbledon a few hours we'll see
if uh the new all-time leader in major
singles titles wants to do a uh 60
Minutes piece Novak Djokovic
he's fascinating
absolutely does he like talking about
being fascinating he loves talking about
being fascinated the fascinating thing
um it's so funny too because you you
watch uh you watch the NBA finals and
there there's another Serbian who
doesn't have much to say no
um this guy's really complicated and he
does some things that are fantastic and
he does some things are just colossally
I mean you wonder who's advising him and
he's kind of happy to talk about all of
it he's he's um yeah I mean he's 36
years old now so we've all sort of
watched this story unfold
um John he's the Aaron Rodgers of tennis
yeah he's Aaron Rodgers of tennis with
um you know with with the Barry Bonds
you know with with the uh with the home
run record I mean for for 15 years
everybody sort of wanted to see who'd
retire with the most majors and he's
moved ahead he's probably not given up
the lead and he's not done and yeah and
he's got this there you're right though
he's got this this Aaron Rodgers side to
him and he's still unvaccinated and he
still plays his first round to the
French Open and he signs the camera with
a message of Kosovo usually athletes run
screaming from yeah yeah this is like an
American athlete signing the something
about the the Dobbs decision one way or
the other I mean did this guy um not
avoid controversy and he's he's really a
fascinating maddening character
safe travels John thanks for joining us
anytime thanks Sam John worthheim 60
Minutes correspondent